the thing about carnage is that it's
unpredictable
Mike Brunson thought he was in charge
when he tried to do a home demolition of
his corn silo get out there with the
sledgehammer and do it yourself how hard
could it be but things didn't go
according to plan
no bail bail indeed but let's just see
around 220 tons of concrete in motion
one more time bail
I'm so happy it was an epic fail because
when I saw this thing it really looked
like the silo was gonna fall all that
guy and I didn't want to see that
standing 65 feet tall and 16 feet wide
the concrete structures stubbornly
stayed upright so why
the structure of is perfectly circular
and an upright so what happens is
there's a lot of compressive force going
down so much force just lined up
perfectly vertical with this that the
little disturbance it has the bottom
still isn't enough to set this thing
swing the point where gravity could take
over and it would fall having escaped
death thanks to the silo superstructure
Mike doesn't give up he realizes he
needs to shift the silo center of
gravity huh
now how would a farmer do that you can
tell this guy he's had it with this silo
right he's gonna defeat the silo so what
he does is he gets his tractor and then
he pulls it down human one silo zero
well it may have been a brush with Jeff
but this video racked up more than two
million hits online making Mike a worthy
king of carnage